and down goes tony martin oh tony martin
you hate to see this you know and
i i don't know what i think of this yet
i've had to take a day to process what i
think of the spectators on the side of
the road but
yeah unfortunately tony martin and that
is the uh
tour de france you know
which is basically steroiding and biking
i've met other friends in it they're all
this whole thing is just a damn
dope show i mean it's basically marilyn
manson
but everybody's real athletic it's
everybody's out here
it's all just i mean they're drinking
each other's blood at night they're
doing it all
you know these people is on anti-freeze
over freeze death
de decadent they're shooting 200 damn
things a decadent right into their damn
armpit
testosterone uh
everything these guys are fired up
they're french and they're fired up
and somebody got in the way with a sign
i'm not going to say who it was it was a
woman
and i'm not going to say who was we
don't allegedly i don't know if they
know who it was yet
but some lady some meme
making [ __ ] whistle
okay and yeah i'm fired up today
got in the way with a sign
so they could get a cute video
while the french
okay no matter what you think about them
um are doing this [ __ ]
and i think they should have let the
guys
i think you almost got to let them go
back and run over the ladies legs with
the bite
that's
it seems fair hope you enjoyed that
video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one